- Bladesmiths,
the steel that you need in
this first round of competition
from these.
Will pulled the cover
off of these things,
and I have one word
that comes to mind--
[bleep]
Today you'll have
to harvest the steel
you need to make your blades
from these motorcycles.
You will have three
hours in this round.
The length of your blades
must be between 9 to 11 inches
long, not including the tang.
The overall length
of your weapon
must not exceed 22 inches.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
Your three hours starts now.
[bleep]
It's pretty nerve
wracking knowing
you're going to have to make
something off of a motorcycle.
First thing that comes to
mind, probably take something
like the chain, which has
a good nickel content,
make a utility camping knife.
Simple, holds up good.
Canister Damascus comes to mind
because that would incorporate
pieces off of the motorcycle,
which is a requirement,
but also give you
enough high carbon
steel from another source to
hopefully get a decent billet
to make a blade.
I've got a heck of a temper.
I'm going to try my
best to not lose it
if something goes wrong, but
I can't promise anything.
Pretty much everybody is
going with the same idea.
Canister Damascus is one
of your only options.
Jonathan, I didn't see
him use any white out
on his Canister Damascus.
I don't know that he has
experience doing [inaudible]..
Hurry up and wait.
Hurry up and wait, brother.
I'm stressed out about whether
or not that Canister Damascus
is going to come out
in one uniform billet,
or if it's going to come out
with spider webs and cracks
all in it.
OK.
Let's make some sparks.
I'm cutting the
side of it off.
I am prying at it with
a chisel and a hammer.
Nothing's happening.
Nothing's working.
I don't like it when
things go wrong.
[bleep]
So I just start prying at
it as hard as I can go,
and little by little, I
get the four sides off.
OK.
Start drawing it out,
thinking everything's great.
Next thing I know,
there's cracks everywhere.
[bleep]
My only plan is kind
of going to crap.
The clock's ticking.
He's in trouble.
So I'm staring at a
pile of metal chunks.
So I've got to come
up with another plan.
Jonathan, he's
going for more parts?
He's going for the
other part of that disk.
Looks like he's
starting from scratch.
Holy--
So I start drawing
out my blade shape
and I'm actually making up
some of the time I lost.
Jonathan's moving that
piece of steel very quickly.
Then I look down, and
that knife doesn't look
like anything I have ever made.
And I don't know if it'll
actually harden at the quench.
10, nine, eight, seven,
six, five, four, three, two.
one.
Bladesmiths, shut down your
machines, drop your tools.
This round is over.
Huge mistake.
That blade wasn't
even 1,100 degrees when
he popped it in [inaudible].
Bladesmiths, in this
first round of competition,
you were to source the
steel that you needed
from a pair of motorcycles.
Now it's time for
the judges to take
a closer look at your work.
Andy, you're up first.
Please present your
blade to the judges.
I understand this was
your first canister weld?
- Yes, sir, it was.
- It's beautiful.
There is warp.
It starts right about there.
But, I mean, it is
one solid piece.
Well done.
Jordan, please present
your blade to the judges.
Well, Jordan, I do like
the shape of your knife.
One question I have for you.
You file checked after
quenching in water.
How did you think
it was ever going
to get harder than
heating it up that hot
and quenching it in water?
I figured I might as well make
a giant fireball to go out in.
I'm just really concerned
about that quench, especially
that last going back in there.
I mean, fireballs are cool,
but hard blades are cooler.
Jonathan, you're up.
Please present your
blade to the judges.
Well, Jonathan, the
handle is comfortable.
I like the swell at the back.
You quenched towards the end.
Let's hope it's hard.
Bladesmiths, the judges have
completed their deliberation
and they've made
a final decision.
The bladesmith
leaving the forge is--
Jordan.
Your blade did not make the cut.
Ben Abbott's going
to tell you why.
Well, Jordan, unfortunately
your last attempt at a quench
failed to harden your blade.
You turned in a soft blade.
Although you and Jonathan
both missed a parameter,
your flaws would be far more
difficult to fix in round two.
So Jonathan lucks out this time.
But, unfortunately, we're
going to have to let you go.
Jordan please
surrender your blade.
I agree with the
judge's decision 100%.
I wasn't expecting
the other blades
to get hard like they did.
At some point in
the future, I sure
do hope that my name
will be listed among some
of the best bladesmiths.